are not specific grants for white males
what specific what should that be why
why should there be they have higher
suicide rates that could possibly be one
reason and then maybe
all the Privileges
excuse me my brothers are white males so
I don't I don't I'm giving you enough
but I'm saying I'm saying I've had I've
had two brothers that tried to commit
suicide and I'm saying it's not they
didn't try to commit suicide because and
I'm not sorry I don't try to bring in
personal City situations I shouldn't do
that but but like it's not because like
they they were thinking oh I have
privileges it's because life can be hard
as a matter